はじめ）今回はこのIPhoneが
天ぷらにされると
された人はどういう反応をするのかという
心理学的な実験を
エイジ）検証ね
はじめ）そう
検証していこうと思います
今回のターゲットは
そらちぃです
エイジ）壊れて
買い直したばっかですね
はじめ）ほうほうほう
今回それとまるっきりそっくりのね
えっと偽物を準備しました
IPhoneのモックでございます
リクヲ）すげー
はじめ）重さとかも一緒なんだよもう
ちなみに僕も多分同じやつですね
おもさちょ重さ重さおおおもさ
エイジ）おお
めっちゃ一緒
はじめ）おなじっしょ
エイジ）ほとんど一緒ですね
いやもうほぼ一緒だよ完全に
こ、どっちがどっちか完全に見分けが付かないくらいの
クオリティとなっております
これがターゲットの使っているIphoneと全く同じ型でございます
でなんか今日ずっと天ぷら作りたいってことを
こう、なんか
朝からちくちく
言ってて
ターゲットは天ぷらの具を買いに行ってます
リクヲ）ふっ
はじめ）でいまから実際に帰ってきて天ぷらを作るんですけども
天ぷらを作っている最中に
僕がターゲットのiPhoneを急に奪い取って
油の中にすり替えたIPhoneを
ぽとっておとします
その時どんな反応をするのか
間違いなく非人道的な行為をする
(笑)
エイジ）絶望ですねｗまじで
はじめ）だからちょっとどうするリアクション考えようぜ
じゃあもう二人はもうドン引きしてよ
エイジ）やりすぎだよ
はじめ）はじめしゃちょーそれはちょっとさすがにないんじゃないんですか？
エイジ）ケースとか
リクヲ）優しさですね　ケースは揚げない
はじめ）一応無害なことをします
怒ってるくらいで　「はじめさんそれはちょっとさすがに・・・。」
(笑)
「やり過ぎですよ」みたいな
なので基本的には天ぷら作り動画みたいなサブチャンネルで撮ってるっていう定でいきましょう
えっ、まって、そんなに容易に手に入れていいの？ｗ
ターゲットのスマートフォンがこちらです
すり替え中
同じだね
まじでわかんないでしょｗ
すり替え中
おおお　完璧　ぴったりだ
分からないよね？
これを俺がキープしてて
リクヲ）既に持ってる状態
はじめ）じゃあ僕が持ったまま今から天ぷら作ってきます
調理開始
はい　いらっしゃいませ
やってきました
天ぷら食べよう皆で
天ぷらを作っていきましょう
小麦粉入れてきます
卵割るのは 6面*が得意なんだよね
*「ロックマンエグゼ」
それはそれですごいよねｗ
リクヲ）温度不足
はじめ）どう？どう？
そらちぃ）情けない天ぷら
スマッシュブラザーズ中
エイジ）ステージ変える？
はじめ）おいそらちぃ
これが何だかわかるか？
そらちぃ）俺の携帯です
取り押さえろ！
え？何？何？何？
そらちぃ）はじめぇーーーー！
ノーリアクション
え？待って待って
見たいんだけど
はじめ）まだ間に合う
そらちぃ）まじで！？
はじめ）うわっ、やばっ
＊焦り＊
はじめ）ドッキリ
大成功
そらちぃ）嘘だぁ
はじめ）本物はちゃんとこっちにあるよ
はじめ）というわけでこちらのスマートフォンは偽物でございました
そらちぃ）よかった～
はじめ）ちゃんとさiPhoneカバーみたくなるんだね